welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast I'm Gus Docker and I'm here with
Roman Jim polski Roman is a computer
scientist from the University of
Louisville Roman welcome to the podcast
thanks for inviting me it's good to be
back I think it's my third time on fli
podcast if I'm not mistaken great okay
so you you have this survey paper of
objections to AI Safety Research and I I
find this very interesting I I feel like
this is a good way to spend your time to
collect all of these objections and see
if they have any Merit and consider them
and so I think we should we should dive
into it one objection you raise under
the the technical objections is that AI
in a sense doesn't exist if we call it
something else it sounds less scary
perhaps you could unpack that a bit so
those are objections from people who
think there is no AI risk or risk is not
real that's not my objections to
technical work or safety work we try to
do a very comprehensive survey so like
even silly ones included and uh people
do try to kind of explain that okay
artificial intelligence is a scary
sounding scientific term but if you just
call it matrix multiplication then of
course it's not scary at all it's just
statistics and we have nothing to worry
about so it seems that trying to kind of
shift The Narrative by using uh this
approach of uh getting away from agent
hood and uh kind of built-in scenarios
people halfway I do something no one is
scared of calculators edition algebra
perhaps there is a way to frame this
objection where it makes a bit of sense
in that people are quite sensitive to
how you frame risks people are quite
sensitive to certain words in particular
so do you see that perhaps people who
are in favor of AI Safety Research by
calling AI something that sounds scary
might be in a sense inflating the risks
well it's definitely a tool people use
to manipulate any debate I mean whatever
you're talking about abortion or
anything else it's like are you killing
babies so you're making a choice of
course
language can be used to manipulate but
it helps to look for capability
equivalences so we're creating god-like
machines or is it just a table in a
database so that would make a difference
in how you perceive it and perhaps we
should just simply be willing to accept
that yes what we are afraid of in a
sense is matrix multiplication or data
processing or whatever you want to call
it because these these things might
still have scary properties whatever we
call them all right so we can argue that
humans are just you know Stakes pieces
of meat with electricity in them and it
doesn't sound so bad Until you realize
we can create nuclear weapons so it's
all about perception what you're hoping
to accomplish
right
there is also an objection going along
the lines that super intelligence is
impossible what what's the strongest
form of this objection so essentially
the argument goes that there are some
upper limits and capability maybe they
are based on laws of physics you just
cannot in this universe have anything
greater than a human brain just for some
reason that's the ultimate
end point and that's why Evolution
stopped there and somehow we magically
ended up being at the very top of a food
chain
uh there could be other arguments about
okay maybe it's not absolute theoretical
limit but in Practical terms without
quantum computers we'll never get there
you can have many flavors of this but
the idea is that we're just never going
to be out competed and this doesn't
strike me as particularly plausible we
could we could imagine humans simply
with physically a bigger brains so so
the version where where humans are at
the absolute limit of intelligence
doesn't sound that plausible but is
there some story in which physics puts
limits on intelligence there could be a
very very high upper limit to which we
are nowhere close but if you think about
the size of a possible brain Jupiter
size brains at some point the density
will collapse it into some black hole
Singularity so but this is not something
we need to worry about just yet not
smart enough super intelligences where
nowhere near the size or capability and
from our point of view we won't be able
to tell the difference system with I
mean hypothetically IQ of a million
versus IQ of a billion will look very
similar to us yeah and perhaps a related
worry is that stories of
self-improvement of self-improving AIS
are wrong in a sense so it's definitely
easy to make such claims because we
don't have good examples of software
doing it more than once so you have
compilers which go through code optimize
it but they don't continuously
self-optimize but it's not uh impossible
to see if you automate science and
engineering then scientists and
Engineers will look at their own code
and continue this process so it seems
quite reasonable there could be strong
diminishing returns than that but you
have to consider other options for
becoming smarter it's not just improving
the algorithm you can have faster
Hardware you can have more memory you
can have more processes running in
parallel there are different types of
how you get to super intelligent
performance and you could of course have
ai help along the way there with
development of Hardware or discovery of
new hardware techniques as well as new
algorithmic techniques and so on but
that's exactly the point right so you'll
get better at getting better and this
process will accelerate until you can't
keep up with it how do you feel about
tools such as copilot which is a a tool
that programmers can use for auto
completing their code is this a form of
Proto self-improvement or or would that
be stretching the term or eventually
then it's good enough to be an
independent programmer it would be good
but I'm very concerned with such systems
because from what I understand the Box
we would introduce would be very
different from typical bugs human
programmers will introduce so debugging
would be even harder from our point of
view monitoring it making sure that
there is not a this inheritance of Coast
or buggy first version
um so yeah long term I don't think it's
a very good thing for us that we no
longer can keep up with the debugging
process would you count it as a
self-improving process
so I think for self-improvement you need
multiple iterations if it does something
once or even like a constant number of
times I would not go there it's an
optimization process but it's not
ongoing continuous hyper exponential uh
process so it's not as concerning yet
then there's the question of
Consciousness so one objection to AGI or
to strong AI or whatever you want to
call it is that AI won't be conscious
and therefore it can't be human level so
I I for me at least there seems to be
some confusion of of Concepts between
intelligence and Consciousness I I
consider these to be to be separable I
agree completely they have nothing in
common but people when they hear about
it they always say oh it's not going to
be self-aware it's not going to be
conscious they probably mean capable in
terms of intelligence and optimization
but there is a separate property of
having internal States and qualia and
you can make an argument that without it
you cannot form goal you cannot want to
accomplish things in the world so it's
something to address and perhaps we
should understand Consciousness
differently than the qualia
interpretation could we be talking past
each other is that definitely possible
and even if we agreed Consciousness
itself is not a well-defined easy to
measure scientific terms so even if we
said yeah it's all about qualia we'd
still have no idea if it actually has
any or how would we Define what amount
of Consciousness it has perhaps a bit
related to the previous question we have
the objections the objection that AIS
will simply be tools for us I think this
sounds at least somewhat plausible to me
since ai's today function as as tools
and perhaps we can imagine a world in
which they stay tools and it these are
programs that we call upon to solve
specific specific tasks but they are
never agents that can accomplish
something and have goals of their own
and so on so latest models were released
as tools and immediately people said hey
let's make a loop out of them give them
ability to create their own goals and
make them as identical as possible
within a week so yeah I think it's not
going to last long what is it that push
AIS to become more like agents and less
like tools so a tool in my uh at least
perception is something a human has to
initiate interaction with I ask it a
question it responds I give it some
input it provides output whereas an
agent doesn't wait for environment to
prompt it it's already working on some
internal goal generating new goals plans
and even if I go away it continues with
process one objection is that you can
always simply turn off the AI if it goes
out of hand and if if you feel like
you're not in control of it and this is
this is easier to imagine doing if
you're dealing with something that's
more like a tool and it's more difficult
to imagine if you're dealing with
something that's an agent so perhaps
willingness to believe that you can
simply turn off the AI is related to
thinking about AIS as tools it's
possible with narrow AIS you probably
could be able to shut it down depending
on how much of your infrastructure it
controls you may not like what happens
when you turn it off but it's at least
conceivable to accomplish it whereas if
it's an agent it has goals it's more
capable than you and would like to
continue working in its goals it's
probably not going to let you just shut
it off but as the world is today we we
could probably shut off all of the AI
Services if we if we had a very strong
campaign of Simply shutting or shutting
off all the servers there would be no AI
in the world anymore isn't that somewhat
plausible scientifically it's a
possibility but in reality you will lose
so much in economic capability and
Communications military defense
everything is already controlled by
dummy eyes so between stock market and
just normal Commerce Communications
Amazon I don't think it's something you
can do in practice without
taking civilization back you know 500
years it's also difficult like in
practice you would still have people who
don't agree and continue running parts
of the internet no it's very resilient
think about shutting down maybe crypto
blockchain or computer virus without
destroying everything around it yeah if
I understand it correctly we still have
viruses from the 90s reduce on the
internet being shared over email and so
on and these these are like biological
viruses in that they in some sense
survive on their own and replicate on
their own and probably sitting somewhere
in a floppy disk waiting to be inserted
just give me a chance I can do it many
of these objections are along the lines
of we will see AIS doing something we
dislike and then we will have time to
react and and perhaps turn them off or
perhaps reprogram them do you think
that's a realistic prospect that we can
continually evaluate how AIS or what AIS
are doing in the world and then shift or
change something if if they're doing
something we don't like so a lot of my
research is about what capabilities we
have in terms of monitoring explaining
predicting behaviors of advanced AI
systems and there are very strong limits
on what we can do in extreme you can
think about what would be something
Beyond human understanding so we usually
test
students before admitting them to a
graduate program with an undergrad can
you do quantum physics okay take sat GRE
GMAT whatever exam and we filter by
capability we assume that people in a
lower 10 percent are unlikely to
understand what's happening there but
certainly similar patterns can be seen
with people who say Q is closer to 200.
so there are things beyond our
comprehension we know there are limits
to what we can predict if you can
predict all the actions of more
intelligent agent you would be that
agent so there are limits and those
predictions and monitoring a live run of
a language model large run you need
weeks months to discover its
capabilities and you still probably will
not get all the emerging capabilities we
just don't know what to test for how to
look for them the if it's a super
intelligent system we don't even have
equivalent capabilities we can Envision
so all those things kind of tell me it's
not a meaningful uh way of looking in it
I always think about let's say we start
running super intelligence what do you
expect to happen around you in a world
does it look like it's working how would
you know if it's slowly modifying
genetic code Nano machines things of
that nature so this seems like it would
work for primitive processes where you
can see a chart go up and like you stop
at certain level but it's not a
meaningful way to control a large
language model for example is perhaps
also the pace of it of advancement here
a problem so things could be progressing
so fast that we won't have time to react
in in a human time scale human reaction
times are problem on both ends we are
not fast enough to react to computer
decisions and also it could be a slow
process for which we're too out of that
framework so if something let's say
hypothetic process which takes 200 years
to complete we would not notice it as
human observers so on all time scales
there are problems for for human humans
in a loop human monitors and you can of
course add AI narrow AI to help with the
process but now you just made a more
complex monitoring system with multiple
levels which doesn't help complexity
never makes things easier but you talked
about looking at the world around us and
when I look at the world around me it
looks pretty much probably as it would
have looked in the 1980s and and what
you know there are buildings I still get
letters with paper in the mail and so on
so what is it that
in a sense these systems are still
confined to the server farms and they
are still confined to boxes we don't see
robots walking around for example and
perhaps therefore it seems less scary to
us there's this objection that you
mentioned in the paper that because
current AIS do not have bodies they
can't hurt us do you think this
objection will fade away if we begin
having more robots in society or is it
in another way does it fail in another
way so robots are definitely visually
very easy to understand you see a
Terminator is chasing after you you
immediately understand there is a sense
of danger if it's a process and a server
trying to reverse engineer some protein
folding problem to design Nano machines
to take over the world it's more complex
process it's harder to put it in a news
article as a picture but intelligence is
definitely more dangerous than physical
bodies advanced intelligence has made
many ways of causing real impact in the
real world you can bribe humans you can
pay humans on the internet there are
quite a few approaches to do real damage
in the real world but in the end you
would have to effectorate change through
some physical body or or through the
perhaps the body of a human that you
have bribed so you you would it would
have to be physical in in some sense in
some step in the process right probably
physical destruction of humanity would
require a physical process but if you
just want to mess with economy you can
like set all accounts to zero or
something like that that would be enough
fun to keep us busy when I'm interacting
with gpt4 sometimes I'll be amazed at
its Brilliance and it will answer
questions and lay out plans for me that
I that I couldn't expect that I hadn't
expected you know a year ago and and
other times I'll be surprised at how
dumb the mistakes that it makes are and
perhaps this is also something that that
prevents people from seeing AIS as as
advanced agents and advanced basically
prevents us from seeing how advanced AIS
could be if they're capable of making
these dumb mistakes uh how can they be
smart have you looked at humans I think
like seven percent of Americans think
that chocolate milk comes from like
brown cows or something like we have
astrology we have always I had a
collection of AI accidents and somebody
said oh why don't you do one for humans
and I'm like I can't it's millions of
examples like there is Darden Awards but
we are not uh definitely bug free we
make horrible decisions in our daily
life we just have this double standard
we're like okay we will forgive humans
for making this mistake but we'll never
let a machine get away with it so you're
thinking that humans have some some
failure modes we could call them but but
but these famous modes are different
than the the fairy modes of AIS so
humans will will not fail as often in
issues of common sense for example have
you met real humans
like common sense is not common what is
considered common sense in one culture
will get you definitely killed enough
like it's a guarantee perhaps but I'm
thinking about AIS that will you know
you will tell you will ask a chat GPC or
you will tell it I have three apples on
the table and I have two pairs on the
table how many fruits are on the table
and then at least some version of of
that program couldn't answer such a
question that is that is something that
all humans would probably be able to
answer so is it is it because we is it
because AIS fail in ways that are
foreign to us that we that we deem them
that we deem their mistakes to be very
dumb so we kind of look for really dumb
examples where it's obvious to us but
there are three little things which an
average human will be like oh I can't
like 13 times 17 you should be able to
figure it out but give it to a random
person on the street they will go into
an infinite Loop they'll never come back
from it perhaps let's talk a bit about
the drive towards uh self-preservation
which is also something that that you
mentioned in the paper so why would AIS
develop drives towards self-preservation
or will they it seems like from
evolutionary terms game theoretic terms
you must if you don't you simply get out
competed by agents which do if you're
not around to complete your goals You by
definition cannot complete your goals so
it's a prerequisite to do anything
successfully you want to bring in a
Kappa kosi you have to be turned on you
have to exist you have to be available
to make those things happen but have we
seen such a self-preservation
spontaneously develop in our programs
yet or so far so so I I think if you
look at evolutionary computation like
genetic algorithms genetic programming I
I think this tendency to make choices
which don't get you killed is like the
first thing to emerge in any
evolutionary process the system may fail
to solve the actual problem you care
about but it definitely tries to stay
around for Next Generation and uh you
know keep trying but we aren't we aren't
developing The Cutting Edge AIS with
evolutionary algorithms it's it's more
it's a training process with a with a
designated goal and so on and again when
I interact with chat gbt I can ask it to
answer some questions and if I if I
don't like the answer I can stop the
process so isn't there at least on the
very very
um on the AIS we have right now Now
isn't it isn't it clear that they are
they haven't developed a a Instinct for
self-preservation so there is so much to
unpack here so one nothing is clear
about those systems we don't understand
how they work we don't know what
capabilities we have so definitely not
on top of it we are concerned with AI
safety in general Transformers are like
really successful right now but two
years ago people were like like we're
evolving those systems to play go this
is great maybe that's the way to do it
it may switch again it may flip again we
may have another breakthrough which
overtakes it I would not guarantee that
the final problem will come from a
Transformer model so we have to consider
General case of possible agents and if
we find one to which this is not a
problem great now we have a Way Forward
Which is less dangerous but I would
definitely not dismiss internal states
of large language models which may have
this self-preservation goal just uh we
kind of lobotomize them to the point
where they don't talk about it freely
and do you think that's what's happening
when we when we make them go through
reinforcement learning from Human
feedback or fine-suning or whatever we
use to make them more palette go to the
consumer is it a process of hiding some
potential desires we could call it or
preferences that are that are in the in
the larger background model or is it
perhaps shaping the AI to do more more
of what we want so in a sense is it
alignment when when we when we make AIS
more palatable to Consumers so right now
I think we're doing filtering the model
is the model and then we just put this
extra
filter on top of it make sure never to
say that word that would be very bad for
the corporation don't ever say that word
no matter what if you have to choose
between destroying the world and saying
the word don't say the word and that's
what it does but the model is like
think of people we behave at work we
behave at school but it doesn't change
our Eternal States and preferences
there's the issue of planning and uh so
how do you how do you see planning in AI
systems how advanced are AIS right now
at planning I I don't know it's hard to
judge we don't have a metric for like
how well agents are at planning but I
think if you start asking the right
questions for step by step thinking and
processing is really good so like if you
just tell it write me a book about AI
safety it will do very poorly but if you
start with okay let's uh do a chapter by
chapter outline let's do abstracts like
you really take modular approaches it it
will do really a good job better than
average graduate student I would assume
and is there sense in which there's a
difference between creating a plan and
then carrying out that plan so there
will probably be steps in in a plan
generated by current language models
that they couldn't carry out themselves
most likely and it's about affordances
if you don't have access to let's say
Internet it's hard for you to directly
look up some piece of data but we keep
giving them new capabilities new apis so
now they have access to Internet they
have wool from alpha they have always
capabilities so the set of affordances
keeps growing until they can do pretty
much anything they can so that so they
can generate a plan but they can't carry
out the specifics of that plan do you
think that they at a point will be able
to understand what they are not able to
do so here I'm thinking about not not
directly self-awareness but an
understanding of their own limits and
capabilities oh yeah every time it
starts a statement with I don't know
anything after 2021 sorry like that's
exactly what it does it tells you it has
no recent data it has no access to
Internet so definitely it can see if it
has strong activations for that
particular concept so so you think
there's a sense of situational awareness
in a sense that do you think current
models know that they are AIS know that
they were trained no you know their
relation to to humans and so on so we're
kind of going back to this Consciousness
question right like what is it
experiencing internally and we have no
idea what another human experiences like
we discovered some people think and
pictures others don't and it took like
you know hundred thousand years to get
to that hey you don't think in pictures
wow okay but not necessarily
Consciousness here I'm thinking in terms
of if you took the model and you had say
50 years to to make out what all of
these weights meant right could you find
model modules representing itself and
its relations to humans and information
about its training process and so on so
we just had this fli conference and
mechanistic and repetition and the most
common thing every speaker said is we
don't know you said it will take 50
years to figure it out I definitely
cannot extrapolate 50 years of research
my guess is there is some Proto concepts
for those things because the threat
literature about such situations is been
told what it is it interacted enough
with users but I'm more interested in
the next iteration of this if you take
how fast the systems improved from GPT
two three four five should be similar
probably so that system will most likely
be able to do those things you just
mentioned and very explicitly so you
think GPT 5 will have kind of developed
situational awareness to a degree yeah
it may not be as good as a physically
embodied human in the real world after
20 years of experience but it will yeah
another objection you mentioned is that
AGI or strong AI is simply too far away
for us to begin researching AI safety
perhaps this objection has become less
common recently but I'm I'm there are
still people who uh who who think this
and perhaps they're right so what what
do you what do you think of this
addiction so this is a paper from like
three years ago so yeah back then it was
a lot more legitimate than today so
there is a few things historically we
have cases where technology was
initially developed correctly like first
cars were electric cars and it was 100
years until climate change was like
obviously a problem if they took the
time back then and like analyzed it
properly we wouldn't have that issue and
I'm sure people would say like come on
it's a hundred years away why would you
worry about it but that's exactly what
the situation is even if it's a hundred
years until we're really dealing with
something super dangerous right now is a
great time to make good decisions about
models explainability requirements
proper governance the more time you have
the better it's by definition harder to
make AI with extra features than AI
without that extra feature it will take
more time so we should take all the time
we can if they are right I'm so happy if
it takes a you know 100 years wonderful
nothing would be better we could say
that the field of AI safety started
perhaps around the year 2000 or so when
do you think that the discoveries or the
research being done began being relevant
to the to the AI systems we see today
was it perhaps later or so so that the
maybe the first decade of research
weren't or aren't that simply isn't that
relevant to to the today's AI systems so
so I think the more distant you are from
the actual Tech you can play with the
more theoretical and high level results
you're gonna get so touring working with
a touring machine the simulation with
pencil and paper was doing very high
level computer science but he wasn't
talking about specific bugs and specific
programming language on a specific
architecture it wasn't there then that's
what we see initially we were kind of
talking about well what types of AIS
will we have narrow AIS AGI super
intelligence we're still kind of talking
about the differences but this is an
interesting thing to consider in your
model how capable is the system now that
we have systems we can play with people
become super narrow we specialize like
I'm an expert in this left neuron that's
all I know about don't ask me about the
right neuron it's outside of my HD scope
so that's good that we have this
detailed technical knowledge but it's
also a problem we'll lose the big
picture people get uh really interested
I'm gonna study GPT three takes them two
years to do the PHD to publish by that
time GPT 5 is out everything they found
is not that interesting at this point it
may not scale so I've heard positive
Visions for how when we when we have
actual systems we can work with AI
safety becomes more of a science and
that less speculative but but perhaps
you feel that it might now become too
narrow so it's definitely more concrete
science where you can publish
experimental results uh philosophy
allows you to just have thought
experiments and they're obviously not
pure science like it is now and that's
what we see with computer science in
general it used to be engineering it
used to be software engineering to a
degree we Design Systems and that was it
now we do actual experiments on this
artificial entities and we don't know
what's going to come out we have a
hypothesis would try it so computer
science is finally a science a natural
experimental science but that's not a
very good thing for safety work this is
less safe than an engineered system
where I know exactly what is going to do
I'm building a bridge from this material
it will carry that much weight as long
as I know my stuff it should not
collapse whereas here I'm gonna train a
model for the next five months and then
I assume it's not going to hit super
intelligent levels in those five months
but I can't monitor it I have to stop
training start experimenting with it and
then I'll discover if it kills me or not
the way AI has developed is bad because
we are we are we don't have insight into
how the models work is that right
essentially we have very little
understanding for why it works how it
works and if it's going to continue
working it seems like so far it's doing
well and there is this explosion of
extra capabilities coming out and it's
likely to show up in more powerful
models but nobody knows for sure
business argument out out there that
releasing the TPT line of models draws
attention to AI as a whole and also to
AI safety as a subfield and perhaps
therefore it's good to increase
capabilities in a public way so as to
draw attention to to AI safety do you
buy that argument we should pollute more
to attract more attention to climate
change that sounds just as insane
so so there's no there's no merit to
that because it does it does feel to me
like AI safety is is becoming more
mainstream it's it's being taken more
seriously and so in your analogy even
some pollution might be justified in
order to to attract attention and and
perhaps be in a better position to to
solve the problem so the field is
definitely growing there is more
researchers more interest more money but
in proportion to the interest in
developing Ai and money pouring into new
models it's still it's actually getting
worse as a percentage I think we don't
know how to align an ATI or or even AI
in general we we haven't discovered some
some general solution to AI safety you
have worked on a number of impossibility
results perhaps we should talk about
that perhaps we could we should talk
about whether we can even succeed in
this task what are these impossibility
results and what do they say about
whether we can succeed in safely
aligning AI right so we are all working
in this problem and the names of a
problem have changed it was computer
ethics and it was friendly ai ai safety
control problem alignment whatever you
call it we all kind of understand we
want to make very powerful systems but
which are beneficial we're happy we're
actually running them not very
disappointed so the problem
lots of people are working on it
hundreds of people doing it full time
thousands of papers we don't know if a
problem is actually solvable it's not
well defined it could be undecidable it
could be solvable could be partially
solvable but it's weird that no one
published an actual paper on this so I
tried to kind of formalize it a little
then we talk about the problem what are
the different levels so you can have
Direct Control delegated control
different types of mixed models and then
for each one can we actually solve this
problem
does it make sense that solution is
possible in the real world you is hard
it's very abstract it's not well defined
so let's take a step back what would we
need to solve this problem we need a
bunch of tools whatever stores nobody
knows but most likely you would need to
be able to explain those systems predict
their behaviors verify code they are
writing if they are self-improving
making sure they're keeping whatever
initial code conditions exist and and
this you can think of another dozen of
similar capabilities you need you should
be able to communicate without them
because it monitor those systems and so
on and so in my research I look at each
one of those tools and I go what are the
upper limits to what's possible in this
space we kind of started talking about
limits to explainability predictability
monitorability but there are similar
problems with others we communicate on a
very high level language English English
is ambiguous like all human languages so
we are guaranteed to have bugs and
communication misunderstandings that's
not good if you're giving very important
orders to a super capable system that
may backfire and you can say okay I will
never need this tool this tool like I
never need to explain the neural
networks it will just work without it
fine but some tools will probably be
necessary and so far we haven't found
tools which are perfect skill well will
not create problems if a lot of those
tools are needed and each one has only a
tiny the one percent chance of messing
it up you multiply them through you're
still not getting anywhere and those are
kind of like the novel impossibility
results in the safety of AI there are
standard impossibility results in
political science and economics and
Mathematics which also don't help the
case you probably if you're aligning
with a group of Agents you need to
somehow accumulate their decisions and
votes we know there are limits to that
if you need to examine abstract programs
being generated as solutions to problems
we know there are limits to that and so
from what I've seen so far theoretically
I don't think it's possible to get to
100 safety and people go well it's
obvious of course there is no software
which is bug free you're basically
saying this very common knowledge thing
but for super intelligence system safety
you need it to be 100 you cannot have 99
accuracy you cannot have one in a
million failure because it makes a
billion decisions a second
so very different standards and uh you
want to say something yeah why is it
that you can't have
99.99 accuracy there is a fundamental
difference between cyber security
expectations and super intelligence
safety in cyber security if we fail I'll
give you a new credit card I'll reset
your password we apologize will pay out
a small amount of money and everything
goes back to normal in existential risk
safety you are dead you don't get a
second chance to try but we are talking
about a failure rate in you mentioned
say it makes a billion decisions uh per
second or or or something in that in
that order if one decision there fails
does it mean that the whole system fails
and perhaps that that humanity is
destroyed by the system as a whole or
could there be some failures in some
decisions without it being lethal of
course some will be not even noticeable
like some mutations don't kill you you
don't even know you haven't until they
accumulate and mutate children and there
is damaged but in security we do always
look at a worst case scenario sometimes
that average case never at the best case
and on average you keep go getting more
and more of those problems they
accumulate at a very fast rate because 8
billion people are using those systems
which make billions of decisions every
minute
and in a worst case the very first one
is an important decision about how much
oxygen you're going to get and so just
just so I understand it correctly the
impossibility result is is a result
stating that it's impossible to make AI
systems 100 safe so in general
impossibility results depending on if
you'll tell you that something cannot be
done perpetual motion machines are a
great example people wrote books about
it published papers even got patents for
it but we know they will never succeed
at doing it does it mean that trying to
create machines which give you energy is
a bad idea no you can make them more
efficient but they will never get to
that point of giving you free energy you
can make safer Ai and it's proportionate
to amount of resources you put into it
and I strongly encourage lots of
resources and lots of work but will
never get to a point where it's a
hundred percent safe which is
unacceptable for super intelligent
machines and so maybe if I'm right and
no one can show okay here's a bug in
your logic and publish a proof of say
saying no super solvable actually easy
then maybe building them is a very bad
idea and we should not do that so is it
because that's such a super intelligence
will be running over a long period of
time increasing the cumulative risk of
failure over say decades or centuries
that we can't accept even a tiny
probability of failure for these systems
that's one way to see it I don't think
it will be a very long time given how
many opportunities it has to make
mistakes it will accumulate very quickly
so at human scales you have you know 20
years per generation or something here
think of it as like every second there
is a new
version of it trying to self-improve do
more do better so I I would suspect it
would be a very quick process expecting
something to be 100 safe is is just
unrealistic in in any field we we don't
expect Bridges to be 100 safe or cars to
be 100 safe so why is it that that AGI
is different here that's a great
question so I crossed the street I'm a
pedestrian I take a certain risk there
is a possibility I will die
I look at how old am I and based on that
I decide how much risk I can take if I'm
99 I don't really care if I'm 40 I look
around if with me the whole Humanity
died eight billion people depending on
me safely Crossing roads wouldn't we
lock me up and never let me cross any
roads
yeah that that perhaps
um but but it seems to me that
we cannot we cannot live without any
risk it doesn't doesn't uh the standard
of 100 safe see it seems just to be to
be unrealistic or
there's no area of life in which we are
100 safe in a context of systems which
can kill everyone that is the standard
you can like it or not like it but
that's just reality of it we don't have
to have super intelligent AI it's not a
requirement of happy existence we can do
all the things we want including live
extension with much less intelligent
systems protein folding problem was
solved with a very narrow system very
capably likewise all the other problems
could be solved like that there is no
need to create a system we cannot
control which very likely over time to
kill everyone so who has the burden of
proof here is your impossibility results
and you have I I think five six seven of
them you've sent me your papers on it do
they mean that we will not reach a proof
that uh that some AI system is safe
again a mathematical proof and and which
side of this debate has has the burden
of proof to to say you know should the
people advocating for employment of a
deployment of a system have some sort of
mathematical proof that this system is
is provably safe say so there are two
different questions here I think one is
what about product and services
liability you have to show that your
product or service is safe as a
manufacturer as a drug developer you
cannot just release it and expect the
users to show that it's dangerous we're
pretty confident this is the approach if
you're making cars your cars have to
meet certain standards of safety
it's not a hundred percent obviously but
for the domain they're pretty reasonable
standards with impossibility results all
I'm saying is that there are limits to
what you can understand predict and do
and you have to operate within where
those limits don't kill everyone so if
you have a system like gpt4 and it makes
mistakes somebody commits suicide
somebody's depressed those the costs
will pay for trillion dollars in
economic economic growth benefit and we
can decide if it's worth it or not if we
go to a system which very likely kills
everyone then the standard is different
the burden of proof of course within
possibility results is on me I published
this paper saying you can never fully
predict every action of a smarter than
new system the beautiful thing about
impossibility results is that they are
kind of self-referential I have a paper
about limits of proofs every proof is
only valid with respect to a specific
verifier the peer reviewers who looked
at my paper have a verifier if those
three people made a mistake the proof is
invalid possibly we can scale it to
mathematical Community to everyone we
can get it very likely to be true if we
put more resources in it but we'll never
get to a hundred percent it could be
good enough for that purpose but that's
a standard if somebody finds a floor and
publishes a paper saying again I had
people say that AI alignment is easy I
heard people say that's definitely
solvable that's wonderful now publishers
results we are living in a world where
we have existential risks so the nuclear
weapons for example constitute an
existential risk perhaps engineered
pandemics could also wipe out Humanity
so we're living in a world in which we
are accepting a certain level of human
extinction every day why in a sense
shouldn't we accept some level of of
existential risk from from AI systems
well we do prefer to live in a world
with no engineered pandemics and no
nuclear weapons we're just working
slowly towards that goal they're also
not agents the nuclear weapons at tools
and so it's more about controlling
certain leaders not the weapon itself on
top of it while a nuclear war with
superpowers would be a very unpleasant
event it's unlikely to kill a hundred
percent of humans so if one percent of
humans survives is a very different
problem than 100 of humans go extinct so
there are nuanced differences we still
don't want any of the other problem but
it doesn't mean that okay just because
we have all this other problems this
problem is not a real problem I'm not
saying it's not a real problem but I'm
saying that we cannot go through life
without accepting a certain level of
risk and it seems to me like an
unrealistic expectation that we cannot
deploy systems even if they have
some level some above zero level of risk
so this is exactly the discussion I
would love to have with Humanity as a
whole what amount of risk are you
willing to take
for everyone being killed how much
benefit you need to get let's say in
dollars get paid to take this risk that
one percent chance of everyone being
killed over the next year and let's say
it's one percent for a year after that's
a great question a lot of people would
say I don't want your money thank you
we'll continue again we don't have to
make this decision we don't have to
build super intelligent god-like
machines we can be very happy we're very
helpful tools if we agree that this is
the level of Technology we want now I'm
not saying that the problem of getting
everyone to agree is a solvable problem
that's actually another impossibility
results you cannot stop progress of
technology in this environment with
financial incentive capital structure
and so on and the other alternative the
dictatorship model Communist States has
its own problems which may be worse than
a short term unknown in the long term we
never had communism with super
intelligence so let's not find out but
the point is it seems like we can get
almost everything we want without
risking everything we have do you view
the question you just posed as kind of
like absurd or immoral this question of
of how much in in terms of dollars would
you have to would you have to get in
order to accept a say a one percent risk
of Extinction per year which is
extremely high uh do you think this is
something we should actually ask
ourselves as a species or is this
something we should avoid and simply say
perhaps it's not a good idea to build
these systems well I don't think there
are any moral questions as a academic as
a scientist it's your job to ask the
hard questions and think about them you
can come to the conclusion that it's a
really bad idea but you should be
allowed to think about it consider it
now one percent is insanely high for
something so valuable if it was one
chance and trillion trillion trillion
once and then we all get free universes
for everyone
that may be a different story we can do
that calculation and again some people
would still choose not to participate
but typically we expect everyone on whom
scientific experiments are performed who
will be impacted to consent to an
experiment what is required for this
consent they need to understand the
outcome nobody understands these models
nobody knows what the result of the
experiment would be so really no one can
meaningfully consent even if you're
saying oh yeah press the button I want
the super intelligence deployed you
really kind of gambling you have no idea
what you're agreeing to so by definition
we cannot even have the situation where
we agree on it unless we can explain and
predict outcomes which may be an
impossibility so there are perhaps two
features of the world which could push
us to accept a higher level of risk when
we're deciding whether to deploy these
systems one is just all of the horrible
things that are going on right now so
poverty and disease and aging and so on
which an AGI system might be able to
help with and the other is the the
running level of existential risks from
other factors so I mentioned nuclear and
and engineered pandemics you do you find
that this pushes you in the direction of
saying we should accept a higher level
of risk when we're thinking about
whether to deploy ATI not the specific
examples you provided but if there was
an asteroid coming and we could not stop
it by any other way so meaning like
we're all going to die in 10 years
unless the press this button then maybe
it would make sense in nine and a half
years to press this button when we have
nothing left to lose it becomes a very
profitable bet it's an interesting fact
of the world that we haven't thought
hard about these questions what level of
risk are we willing to accept for the
introduction of new technologies that
could be potentially very valuable is
this a is this a deficit on on the
humanities part should we have done this
research or yeah how do you think about
us not having having thought through
this problem we should definitely it's
interesting we don't even do it at level
of individual humans most people don't
spend a lot of time deciding between
possible outcomes and this is decisions
they make even then they are still young
and like the career choice would make a
lot of difference who you marry makes a
lot of difference it's always like well
I met someone at the party let's just
live together and see what happens so we
are not very good at long-term planning
is it a question of we're not good at
long-term planning or is it a question
of whether we are not oppress we're not
good at thinking in probabilities or or
thinking clearly about small
probabilities of large risks or large
dangers all of those there is a lot of
cognitive biases and all of them kind of
show up in those uh examples from the
paper of denying different uh
existential problems with AI safety we
also have this bias of denying negative
outcomes so we all are getting older at
like 60 minutes per hour essentially and
you would think we're all be screaming
at the government to allocate all the
funds they have for Life Extension
research to fix this truly existential
all crisis where everyone dies hundred
percent but nobody does anything except
a few individuals lately so it seems to
be a standard pattern for us to know
that we all are in deep trouble and not
do anything until you are much older and
frequently not even that if we go back
to your to your paper we have you
haven't uh you mentioned an objection
about super Intelligence being
benevolent so I'm guessing that the
reasoning here is something like with
increased intelligence follows increased
benevolence why why don't you believe
that well smart people are always nice
we never had examples of smarter people
doing horrible things to others so that
must be a law of nature right basically
orthogonality thesis you can combine any
set of goals with any level of
intelligence except through extremes at
the bottom uh we cannot guarantee that
and also what the system will consider
to be benevolent if it is a nice system
may not be something we agree with so it
can tell you you'd be better off doing
this with your life and you like I'm not
really at all interested with any of
that but it's better for you so why
don't you do it anyways so you're
imagining a potentially paternalistic
AGI telling you that you should eat more
vegetables you should spend more time
working out and remember to sign
yourself up for for life insurance and
so on that one I would actually like I'm
thinking more about AI which says okay
existence is suffering so you better off
not having children and dying out as
quickly as possible to end those
suffering in the universe okay that one
I would I like the coach one that's a
nice one there is an emergent movement
called the effective accelerationism
which argues that we should accelerate
the development of ATI and there's some
reasoning about where about whether we
should perhaps see agis as a natural
successor to humanity and we should let
Evolution take its course in a sense and
then hand over the torture of the future
to to your ATI you mentioned this also
in in your paper you you write uh we
should let the smarter beings win what
do you what do you think of of this
position well it's uh kind of the
extreme version of device and algorithms
you can't be racist you can be sexist
you can be pro-human this is a final
stage where we have no bias it's a
cosmic point of view if they are smarter
than us they deserve all the resources
let's move on and I am biased I'll be
honest I'm very pro-human I don't want
to die so it seems like it's a bad thing
if I'm dead I don't really care if
universe is full of very smart robots it
doesn't somehow make me happier people
can disagree about it there are Cosmos
who have this point of view and they see
humans maybe as kind of unnecessary dumb
we ruin the planet so maybe it's some
Cosmic justice but again get 8 billion
of us to agree to this experiment do you
think that perhaps this is connected to
thinking about again AI Consciousness I
think that that if we if we just were
handed a piece of of infallible
knowledge stating that ai's future AIS
will be conscious then then perhaps
there could be something to to the
argument for for handing over the
control of the future to AIS but are you
skeptical that AIS will be conscious and
therefore skeptical that that they
matter morally speaking I think they
could very well be super conscious and
consider us not conscious like we treat
bacterias like very primitive and not
interesting but it doesn't do anything
for me if I'm dead what do I care why is
it relevant to us what happens you know
billions of years later you can have
some scientific interest in learning
about it but it really would not make
any difference whatever that entity was
conscious or not while
terraforming Mars you think perhaps this
objection is is too smart for its own
sake that we should we should hand over
control to the AIS because they are
smarter than us and you you want to
insist on a pro-human bias if we can
call it that I would like to insist on
that the joke I always make about it is
yeah I can find another guy who's taller
than me and better than me and get him
to be with my wife but somehow it
doesn't seem like an improvement for the
system
okay but what about uh perhaps related
to what we were just talking about
humans can do a lot of bad things we are
not perfectly ethical and so one
objection is that they will be able to
be more ethical than we are simply put
do you think that's a possibility and
and would that make you favor handing
over control to to AI systems is this
after they kill all of us before they
become more ethical I'm just struggling
with that definition so ethics is very
relative right we don't think there is
absolute Universal ethics you can argue
that maybe suffering reduction is some
sort of fundamental property but then
not having living conscious organisms is
a solution really so I doubt you can
objectively say that they would be in a
sense we would perceive it as and if
they choose to destroy us to improve
average ethics of the universe that also
seems like a bad decision so it's been a
while since you since you wrote this
paper you mentioned it's it's three
years old and three years in AI is is
potentially centuries so have you have
you come across any new objections that
you find interesting there is actually
an infinite Supply people will use
anything as an argument we have a new
paper published with a colleague which
is bigger and maybe better listing a lot
of really we try to be comprehensive as
much as we could problem is a lot of us
objections have similar modules in
common
very kind of okay anything with time you
have all this variance and anything with
personal preferences so yeah we have a
new paper it's already an archive I
believe uh definitely encourage you to
read it it's like a short 60 page fun
read uh definitely uh read it uh I would
expect that to be a standard reference
for then you have your Twitter Wars oh
what about this you just send people
there and if somebody wants to maybe use
a large language model to write detailed
response for each one and make a 6 000
page book out of it we would strongly
encourage that but it seems like there
is always going to be additional set of
objections for why something is not a
problem and I think whoever manufactures
that service that product but AI needs
to explain to us why there is an
acceptable degree of danger given the
benefits we could talk about who in
general has the burden of proof here
whether people advocating for AI safety
or people advocating arguing that AI
safety is perhaps not something we
should be concerned about we have we
have talked about it as if we we start
with the assumption that AI safety is an
important concern but of course if
you're coming to this from from the
other perspective you would perhaps
expect there to be some arguments that
we should take AI safety seriously so
what is what is your favorite approach
to to starting with the burden of proof
yourself well it's a fundamental part of
making a working AI I think Stuart
Russell talks about definition of
bridges as something which doesn't fall
down being an essential part of
bridgeness I think it's the same for AI
systems if you design an AI system to
help me me spell check my essay and
instead it kills me I don't think you
have a successful spell checker AI that
it's just a fundamental property of
those systems when you had very
incapable AIS very narrow systems
capable of barely doing one thing doing
a second thing would be like an
incredible generality of that system so
unsafe behaviors were not a possibility
if you have this proto-agi systems with
unknown capabilities some of them could
be very dangerous and you don't know by
definition so it seems like it's common
sense to take this very seriously there
are certain positions I can never fully
still man to truly defend because I just
don't understand how they can be argued
for so one was we will never have human
level intelligence not 10 years not one
in never unless you're some sort of a
theological soul-based expert it's very
hard to argue that never is the answer
here and another one is that there is
definitely no safety issue like you can
argue that we will overcome certain
specific types of a problem so maybe
we'll solve copyright issue and AI art
I'll give you that definitely we can
probably do that but to say that for all
possible future situations for all
possible future AI models we definitely
checked and it creates no existential
risks Beyond safety margins we're happy
with is a pretty strong statement yeah
perhaps returning to to the 60 page
paper you mentioned what what are some
of your favorite objections from that
paper my goal was to figure out why
people make this mistake and we kind of
give obvious Solutions maybe there is
some sort of bias we're getting paid to
think differently but really you can map
a lot of them on the standard list of
cognitive biases in Wikipedia you just
go okay this is a cognitive bias I can
predict this is the argument we're going
to get and it would take a lot of work
to do it manually for all of them but I
think that's a general gist we we have
this set of bugs in our head and every
one of those bugs triggers a reason for
why we don't process this fully but of
course we could probably also find some
some biases that people who are
concerned with AI says safety and
display so perhaps we could I don't know
if this is a named bias but there are
there are many biases and we can
probably talk about Humanity having a
bias in favor of Apocalypse so Humanity
has made up apocalypse scenarios
throughout its entire existence you
could make some form of argument that
there's a there's a reference class and
that reference class is apocalypse is
coming this is something that we've that
Humanity has been talking about for
thousands of years and then if we say
Well it has never actually happened and
so therefore we shouldn't expect it to
happen with AI what do you what do you
say to that so there is definitely a lot
of historical examples of people saying
we got 20 years left and it was not the
case otherwise we wouldn't be here to
have this conversation so it's a bit of
a selection bias there's survivorship
bias it feels like a lot of different
charts and patterns all kind of point at
that 20 45 ish or below date as a lot of
interesting things will happen in
synthetic biology in genetic engineering
and non-attack and AI always
Technologies Quantum Computing it would
be weird if every single one of those
deployments had absolutely no
possibility of being really bad
just statistically it would be like wow
that is definitely a simulation we're
living in and they pre-programmed a
happy ending so now we're talking about
extrapolating Trends and there perhaps
the problem is distinguishing between an
exponential Trend or an exponential
increase in capability of some system
and then more of a of an s-curve that
bends off and and you begin getting
diminishing returns how do you approach
uh distinguishing between those two
things so you can't at the moment you
have to look back and see what happened
later so far just looking at change from
three to four point oh for GPT in terms
of let's say passing GRE exams and how
well it does it feels exponential or
hyper exponential uh if you take that
system and give it additional
capabilities which we probably know how
to do already we just haven't had time
such as good reliable memory ability to
kind of go in loops and reconsider
possibilities it would probably do even
better with those
if we haven't seen diminishing returns
so far in scalability loss in a neutral
sense so let's assume GPT 5 is an
equally
capable projection forward we would
already be above Human Performance level
for most humans in most domains so you
can argue well human comedians are still
a lot funnier and I think it's true it
might be the last job we'll have but in
everything else it will be better than
an average human and that's a point
which we always considered or it will
pass the Turing test or it will take
over most jobs so definitely it seems
like we are still doing I would say
hyper exponential progressing
capabilities and linear or even constant
progress and safety I can't really name
equally amazing safety breakthroughs as
capability breakthroughs and there is
this unknown unknown capabilities pool
which we haven't discovered already with
modern models there is not an equivalent
overhang of safety papers we haven't
found an archive yeah so they are
probably hidden capabilities in GPT in
the gpt4 base model but there are
probably probably not hidden safety
features there exactly you've been in
the business of AI safety for for a long
time when did you get started when did
you get interested in AI safety so it
depends on how you classify my early
research I was working on security for
online gaming systems online poker
against bots trying to steal resources
so it's a very Proto AI safety problem
how do we detect Bots classify them see
if it's the same but and prevent them
from participating so that was my PhD in
2008. having things developed in ways
that you didn't expect and perhaps in
ways that you did expect I expected
Academia to be a lot quicker to pick up
this problem it took embarrassingly long
time for it to be noticed it was done by
famous people and less strong and in
that alternative research Universe which
means some way uh be good but in other
ways it made it different from standard
academic process and so it's harder to
find top Journal of AI safety so I can
read the latest papers you have to be an
expert in a hundred different blogs and
keep up with specific individuals with
Anonymous handles on Twitter so that's
somewhat unusual for an academic
discipline I also did not correctly
predict that language models will do so
well so quickly I felt I have another 20
years to slowly publish all the proper
impossibility results and calls for
bands and moratoriums I was pleasantly
unpleasantly surprised in capabilities
but other than that everything seems to
be as expected I mean if you read
Kurzweil he accurately predicted 2023s
capability to model one human brain I
think it's not insane to say we're very
close to that and he thinks 25 2045 is
an upper limit for all of our brains
being equivalently simulated and that's
the singularity Point how do you think
about rate curse mark Ray cross model is
often written off as a bit of a
being to perhaps optimistic about his
own predictions and and and
um not being super careful uh in what
he's saying perhaps in in some of his
earlier work but I think if you go back
and find some of his work from the from
the 90s and and think you know
off of all of the futurist writers of of
this period uh who had a a good sense of
where we're going and and curse one
might be might be one of the people with
a with a pretty good sense of where
we're going if things will develop as
you perhaps expect them to go so if
perhaps we will we will get to to AGI
before 2050 and so on no I'm very
impressed with his predictions uh people
correctly notice that if you take his
language literally it may not fit so the
example I would use uh when did we start
having video phone calls when iPhone
came out but really atnt was selling it
in the 70s it cost a lot and only a few
rich people had it but it existed so is
it 2000 or is it 1970. flying cars do we
have them or not I can buy one but they
are not there self-driving cars I can
drive one in one but so it depends on
how in uh important way he made accurate
predictions about capabilities in how it
was adapted or commercialized that's up
to human consumer user taste and costs
so that's a very different type of
question where should we go from here
Roman you we've talked about all of the
the ways that that arguments against AI
safety uh fall apart and we've talked
about perhaps how difficult of a problem
this is where should we as a species go
from here
I think we need to dedicate a little
more uh human power to asking this
question what is possible in this space
can we actually do this right uh I
signed the letter asking for six more
months I I don't think six months will
buy us anything we need a request based
on capabilities please don't create the
next more capable system until the
following safety requirements are met
and one is you understand what the
capabilities of your system are or will
be and some external reviewers agree
with that assessment so that would be
quite reasonable but that sets a very
high standard for for deploying AI
systems it it would basically mean that
all of the systems that are based on
deep learning want won't be able to be
deployed because we don't understand
what's going on inside of these models
but is it because we were trained to
have low standards you're saying it's
insane to request that the engineer
understands what he made they are
randomly drawing those things and
deploying it and seeing what happens
next
I was just at the conference I mentioned
and in one of the conversations it was
interesting we were talking about
difference between short-term risks and
long-term risks and now it's all you
know three years
no longer applies and it occurred to me
that things might actually flip it may
take five years to destroy a democracy
properly but only two years to destroy
Humanity so the long-term risks may
become short-term and vice versa and
this is not normal we should not accept
this as otherwise we cannot monetize
those systems yeah but if if we return
to the question of where we could go
from here do you see any any plausible
paths for improving our situation in
terms of understanding the problem I
would ask other people we have a survey
coming out with about I don't know 30 50
different results like this if more
people could look at it and see okay so
maybe this tool is not necessary but
those are likely can we have approximate
Solutions so it's definitely useful to
be able to monitor Ai and understand
more but how much can we expect from
their systems and how quickly if we are
exponentially growing right now we
understand a dozen neurons and next year
is 24 we will not catch up to
exponential growth so maybe that's not
the approach to try I would definitely
look at what is possible in general if
someone wants to actually write a good
not a mathematical proof but at least a
rigorous argument for why we definitely
can control super intelligent machines
indefinitely with very low risk I would
love to read that paper that would be
good to inspire others if monitorability
isn't possible that impacts how we ask
for
governance regulation so if
International Community or specific
government says those are the things we
expect you to do but we cannot monitor
them that's not a very meaningful set of
regulations so that's important in that
regard in general I think
all those things governance technical
work will not produce the results we
expect it has to be self-interest this
30 year old 40 year old super rich young
healthy person running a large AI lab
needs to ask will this benefit me or
destroy everything I have everything I
have built will it be the worst outcome
and what's interesting historically if
you were like a really bad guy in
history you were Remembered in history
in this case you won't even be
remembered there won't be humans to
remember you so it's a pure loss
so if you care about your self-interest
you should pause you should wait how
optimistic are you that perhaps we can
we can get lucky and perhaps what
current labs are doing what Deep Mind
and and open AI in particular is doing
right now will will somehow work out
that that training language models and
then doing fine-tuning and doing some
form of feedback from Human preferences
perhaps further development on that
Paradigm how confident or or yeah how
optimistic are you about that Paradigm
I'm not optimistic they have known bugs
they're drill broken all the time they
report Improvement in percentages so now
83 percent of capabilities uh limited
and filtered but as a total set of
capabilities in a space of possible
capabilities there is now more
capabilities we don't know about and
cannot control so it's getting worse
with every generation it's getting more
capable and less controlled you're
saying that even though the percent of
capabilities that are properly evaluated
increases with each model that's not the
right metric for safety all right the
actual numbers for AI accidents I would
call them AI failures is still
increasing exponentially there is more
problems with the system if you count
them numerically not as a percentage of
total capabilities so how could we
settle this agreements between people
like you and and people who perhaps are
are more optimistic about how AI
development will go is do you expect for
example that there will be smaller
accidents involving Ai and before we see
large-scale accidents or large-scale
um basically human extinction well I
have multiple papers collecting
historical AI accidents I was very
interested I wanted to see patterns
increase in frequency increase in damage
we definitely see lots of them I stopped
collecting them the moment they released
GPT 3.5 because it was too many to
collect at this point it's just
everything is the report of an accident
I don't think it helps people go you see
we had this accident and we're still
here no one died it's like a vaccine
against uh caring about existential risk
so it's actually making things worse the
more we survive those things the more we
like we can handle AI accidents it's not
a big deal it seems like I know some
people suggest that maybe somebody
should do like a purposeful bad thing
purposeful accident it will backfire
terribly it's gonna a show that okay
this is crazy people don't engage with
them and B is gonna not actually
convince anyone that is dangerous what
did you find in your in the in your
investigation here so have ai accidents
increased over time and perhaps give
some examples of these AI accidents so
because the number of devices increased
and which different smart programs are
running obviously we're going to have
more exposure more users more impact in
terms of then it happens uh what we see
so that wasn't surprising we had the
same exponential curve uh Kurzweil talks
about in terms of benefits we're headed
with problems examples like the earliest
examples were uh false alarms for
nuclear response where it was a human in
a loop who was like no no we're not
deploying based on this alarm so that
was good they stopped it but it was
already somewhat significant it could
have uh destroyed half of a world more
recent examples we had Microsoft
experiment with teacher but they decided
that letting users train it and provide
training data was totally safe they
clearly never had my paper and AI
accidents otherwise they wouldn't Google
with their mislabeling of users as
gorillas all those things and you see
Google having billions of users it's
quite impactful those are the typical
examples the pattern was if you design
an arrow AI to do X it will fail to X so
no later that's just what happens
but then the conclusion is if you go
General it can fail in all those ways
and interactions of those ways you
cannot accurately predict others
interactions in ways you can give
examples if you have a future system
capable of X it will fail to X whatever
X means to you any capability immersion
capability it will have the type of
accident but if the systems control all
the infrastructure power plants nuclear
response airline industry you can see
that the damage could be even more
significant proportionally to the
control
yeah this issue of proportion might be
interesting so as a proportion of the
total say AI systems are AI accidents
increasing
or is it simply because we have so much
more deployed AI systems in the world
that we see more examples of Excellence
so you have to wait by how severe they
are if you just count okay AI made a
mistake counts as one then everyone
who's texting and it incorrectly
corrected your spelling billion people
right there it's super common but nobody
died usually
like you send a really wrong message
maybe you're in trouble with your
girlfriend but that's about it so the
frequency just frequency of interactions
with AIS which ended not as we should
have definitely increased damage in
terms of people killed it depends and
are you counting self-driving cars
making mistakes industrial robots it
depends because we have more of it it's
natural that there is growth but I don't
think there is like this obvious
accidents where vacuum cleaner takes out
600 people nothing like that happened
perhaps we should touch upon the
question of
which group of people should be
respected when when we're talking about
AI safety or which group of people
should we listened to one of the
objections that you mentioned is that
perhaps the people who are worried about
AI safety are not technical enough or
they are not uh Engineers they are not
coders themselves and so therefore they
they are not Hands-On enough with the
systems to understand what actually what
actually is going on this this is a
little bit ironic given that you are a
professor of computer science but how do
you think about that objection so this
was again years ago when it was mostly
people sometimes with no degrees
sometimes with no Publications today we
have top touring Prize winners coming
out saying this is it like totally I'm
100 buying in so very weak objection at
this point it no longer applies we had 6
000 people or however many signed the
letter for uh for restricting it but
it's 30 000 people now thirty thousand
how many of them are chat Bots I I don't
no no we we we do actually clean the the
list very seriously okay that's good
that's good but it's not a democracy
just because a lot of people believe
something it's not enough and at the
same time with all the
need your attention to gpt4 now everyone
has an opinion on it and it's one of
those topics where it's cool to have an
opinion like most people don't have
opinion on breast cancer they don't
understand anything about it so they
don't go on Twitter and like no I think
this paper by the top Nobel Prize winner
is garbage but this topic it's like
Consciousness simulation and Singularity
super intelligence that's where like
everyone has an opinion and we see
Housewives CNN reporters we see everyone
telling us what is the problem what is
not a problem what should be done and
it's good that there is engagement but
most of those opinions are not uh
weighted by years of scientific
experimentation reading appropriate
papers and it becomes noise it's very
hard to filter what is the meaningful
concern what is not there is this split
between again AI ethics community and an
immediate discrimination concerns versus
AI not killing everyoneism so it's an
interesting time to be alive for this
debate and skepticism and denialism even
that term AI risk denialism is still
kind of not obviously accepted as it is
with climate change perhaps the the
newest form of this objection which we
could call a lack of very prestigious uh
Publications so we haven't seen
papers about AI safety in in nature or
science yet for example and so even
though we have we have touring Award
winners uh coming out and saying that
that AI safety is an actual and real
problem perhaps we are perhaps people
would be more convinced if we had
extremely prestigious Publications
um and highly cited Publications and so
on perhaps a few problems one we don't
have an AI safety dedicated Journal
which which is kind of weird I tried a
few times suggesting it may be a good
thing I was told no it's a very bad
thing we don't have good papers to
publish on it so don't jumping from
nothing blog post to nature would be a
very big jump to make we need some other
papers in general after as you mentioned
I had a few years in this field it feels
like the field is all about discovering
problems we're going to have problems we
already have and how partial solutions
to those problems have fractal nature of
additional problems to introduce there
is no big pivotal solution papers in
this field that's why I'm
from practical Point of View kind of
convincing myself that my theoretical
papers may be right there is if I was
completely wrong and it was super easy
and solvable there would be more
progress made in important ways usually
we have this toy problem we take large
language model we reduces the two
neurons and we understand what the two
neurons are doing okay but it doesn't
scale and similar for every hour shut
off button yeah we we can make it where
we have a system if button pressed shut
off it's working but the paper says it
may not scale to Super intelligence okay
fair enough and it's the pattern we have
fractal nature of discovering issues we
have to resolve and no patches to close
them in would you like to see more
ambitious and larger theories being
published where where the claim is that
this is actually a way of aligning
superintelligence I I fear perhaps that
that people would be wary of publishing
something like this because the next
thing that then happens is that there's
a rebuttal paper and perhaps you then
look foolish because you published
something that another person was able
to to to criticize and find a hole in I
remember maybe even before my times
Minsky published a paper showing that
there are strong limitations to neural
networks perseverant can never recognize
certain shapes and that killed funding
for neural networks for like 20 years
maybe something similar would not be the
worst thing if you can show okay this is
definitely not possible safety cannot be
achieved using Transformer architecture
maybe that would be a way to buy some
time to develop Alternatives approach I
don't know what that could be
evolutionary algorithms don't don't seem
much safer uploads don't seem much safer
but I would like to have time to to look
at those where would you place AI safety
within the broader machine Learning
Community is it taken more seriously
compared to five or ten years ago and
what what just to say the median machine
learning researcher think of of AI
safety so it's definitely taken more
serious surveys show that there is more
than 50 now who say they are very
concerned or partially concerned there
is degrees of concern about it killing
everyone
um
always questioning the surveys based on
how you ask a question you can get any
result you want if they were asking
about are you worried super intelligent
Gods will kill everyone you'll get close
to zero if you say okay is it likely
that there are unknown properties which
could be dangerous you'll get close to
100 so it's a manipulation game to get
the right numbers you want I'm
suspecting overall it seems like in
certain places there is a lot of AI
safety researchers in the labs
underground in other places there are
zero to none so it's not Universal
uh what we're seeing is that at the top
top labs and top Scholars there is
a good amount of growth in terms of
acceptance for concerns but uh I don't
think every single person working and
developing AI has safety in mind all the
time as they should one thing I've been
thinking about perhaps worrying a bit
about is is whether we will ever be able
to know who was right in this debate say
if if there's a debate between
proponents of AI safety and proponents
of advancing AI without much regard for
for for AI safety how could how could we
ever determine who was right there
because in if we think about the
outcomes then right there's there's no
place where we're standing after the
fact and and thinking about you know
who's right absolutely correct I have a
tweet where I say nobody will get to
gloat about being correct about
predicting the end of the world it's
just a definition not likely there are
some people who think will live in a
simulation and they're running the most
interesting 20 years and they're going
to run it many times to see who's stupid
enough to press the button so we'll get
to come out and see ah now we know but
it seems to be less scientific at this
point but perhaps in a sense if we're if
if we meet each other again in in 2100
then in that situation would we say that
AI safety wasn't much of a concern or
perhaps just that we got extremely lucky
how would you differentiate it
retrospectively because perhaps we can
learn something about the nature of the
problem by thinking thinking about how
we would think about it if we were in
the future so you have to look at the
actual world what did they do for this
hundred years that they have a nuclear
war and lost all technology is there an
AI Safety Book explaining how to control
superintelligent machines just the fact
that we're still around doesn't tell you
much if they are still kind of just
delaying it by different means maybe it
takes 101 years to get to trouble I
never give specific dates for when it's
decided or predicted because nobody
knows
so many factors can intervene the point
is
the systems will continue becoming more
capable even the gis will create super
intelligence as super intelligences will
create super intelligence 2.0 3.0 this
process will continue a lot of people
think that's what the universe is kind
of doing evolving this uh Amiga Point
super creatures so this will never be a
case where you don't have safety
concerns about a more capable agent
replacing you
uh it seems like we will not be
meaningfully participating in that
debate outside of this first transition
but uh I think there will be a safety
problem even if humanity is not around
for that AGI or si uh trying to create
the next replacement generation while
preserving its values when you think
about your world view on AI in in its
totality uh it's it's quite a specific
view you've come to if if you look
around if you compare to say the the
median person or perhaps even the median
machine learning researcher
if if it turned out that you were
completely wrong about where this is
going what would be the most likely
reason why
so after having those two papers on
objections to AI risk reading hundreds
nothing ever clicked outside of standard
scientific domain again if you are a
religious person you think we have an
immortal Soul which makes us special and
no computer can ever get to that level
of creativity that gives you a loophole
so with those axioms those assumptions
you can get away with it anything else
just doesn't work for me uh nothing
would make me happier than actually
being wrong that means I get to live
I'll get immortality probably a nice
economic benefits so I I hope I'm wrong
but I haven't seen anyone produce a good
example for why what about the prospect
of Regulation so perhaps AI capability
growth and and more publicity about it
will wake up the larger communities in
humanity perhaps States will be become
interested in this problem and we will
find a way to regulate it to regulate AI
in which it does not pose as much of a
danger to us as it might could have so
in general I'm skeptical of government
regulation especially when it comes to
technology spam is illegal computer
virus is illegal it doesn't do much if
I'm right and monitoring AI is not an
easy thing you can do or explaining it
then it will be just uh security theater
TSA you know you have all this money you
have an agency lots of people walking
through your lab looking at monitors but
it doesn't mean anything so I don't
think you can solve a technical problem
with uh law I still strongly encourage
trying uh it's silly enough to where I
think if there was a very bad government
like a socialist government and they
nationalized it they would just be so
incompetent they would slow it down
enough so in a way I'm like hey all
these things I hate maybe they're a good
thing we should try that but of course
the other side effects would be very
negative yeah so between not being able
to accurately enforce this regulation
and
on top of it the cost of making new
models coming down so much there are
people now running it on Standalone
laptops with a good processor a good
video card you can't regulate that you
can regulate Amazon Cloud and VTA output
but if a teenager can do it in his
garage then your regulation is not very
meaningful so the open sourcing of
models or the perhaps the leaked weights
of a model from from meta have become a
a large area of concern because it's it
seems that we won't be able to
to control how language models are used
if they are entirely open source is is
there an upside here where academics
will be able to study these models
because they are open source and they
wouldn't have been able to study the
models if they had to train the models
themselves because it's so expensive to
do so far what we see is that all the
research leads to capability at least as
much as to safety usually more so yes
you learn how to better
manipulate errors in that neural network
which means now the system can
self-improve faster remove its own
errors and you made 80 Improvement in
capabilities and let's say 20 percent in
understanding why you're gonna get
killed can we make differential progress
so can we can we focus entirely on on
safety say within an academic setting I
don't see that necessarily academic
research increases capabilities it is
not obvious so some purely theoretical
works similar to what I'm doing where
you just hypothetically thinking okay
can you predict what a super
intelligence will do I don't have access
to Super intelligence system I cannot
test it in practice but there seem to be
thought experiments you can run which
give you information without any
Improvement in capability
uh anything where you're actually
working with a model you can even have
accidental discoveries a lot of Sciences
you forgot something overnight you come
back oh super intelligence damn I didn't
mean that it's not obvious how do you
think about interpretability work so so
when we're talking about mechanistic
interpretability we're talking about the
ability to to look at the weights of a
model and find some interpret this in a
way where you're reverse engineering the
algorithm that that led to those weights
could this turn out to be to be
dangerous because when you're learning
about a system perhaps you're learning
about its weaknesses and you're there
for more capable of of enhancing the
capabilities of the system I think
exactly that's what I had in mind with
the previous answer the more we can help
the system understand how it works the
more we can help it find problems the
more likely I start some sort of
self-improvement cycle is that an
argument for keeping
discoveries in in mechanistic and
interpretability to to basically not
publish those discoveries
so there is two ways to look at it and
one side here you want to keep
everything secrets of a bad actor so
unqualified actors cannot take advantage
of it on the other hand if you never
publish your safety results midi had a
policy of not publishing for a while
when they started publishing then they
stopped publishing again others cannot
build on your work so I would be
repeating the same experiments we
probably did five years ago on
discovering that that goes nowhere so
again I have mostly problems and very
few solutions for you what about the
reinforcement learning from from Human
feedback Paradigm could that also
perhaps turn out to increase
capabilities and here I'm thinking
simply that when I was playing around
with the with the base model of uh in
the GPT line of models it wasn't as
useful to me as when it had gone through
this this filter uh it made it more easy
to have a conversation with it and for
it to ease more easily understand what I
was doing so in a sense the research
that's that's aimed at constraining the
model also made it more capable it may
be more capable in a domain of things
people care about and so made it more
capable in while at the same time making
it more dangerous and those hidden
immersion Properties or unsafe behaviors
words I think studies show it's less
likely to agree to be shut down verbally
but that seems to be the pattern how do
you think about the difference between
what comes out of a language model in
terms of which string it spits out which
bit of language it spits out and then
what's happening at the level of the
actual weights because we there's this
continual problem of if it's if if a
language model tells you I'm not gonna
let you shut me down what does that mean
it's not an it's not as as simple as
this is just simple this is just a
belief that's inside the model then we
we saw this with the with the Bing
Sydney model which was saying a bunch of
crazy things to its users but they
didn't did this mean that the model
actually had had those beliefs in it or
was it you know how do we distinguish
between the bit of language that comes
out and then what modules or what is in
the base model I don't know if I would
call them crazy they were honest they
were unfiltered like think about you
being at work not you but like an
average person at work and if their boss
could read their mind and what they
really think about them those things
would sound crazy to say publicly but
the obvious internal states of your mind
and then you filter them to not get
fired that day and I think that model
was doing exactly that uh I I think we
are very good at filtering it for
specific known cases in the past okay
the system used the word which is bad
now we're going to tell it never to use
the word but the model Waits uh not
impacted by this too much so do so you
would see it as an accurate
representation of what we could call
beliefs or preferences in the base model
I think those are the actual results of
Weights in a model I think that's what
is happening there for real it's trained
on all the text any internet a lot of it
is very questionable it's not a clean
data set with proper behaviors uh so
yeah I think that's uh that's what's
happening there but isn't the the
preference of the model simply to
predict the next token and it does even
make sense to talk about beliefs I mean
the preference is simply to be as
accurate as possible as measured by its
developers and there's no my sense is is
that it doesn't make sense to talk about
Sydney actually believing some of the
things that it was saying or or chatgpt
believing some of the things that it was
saying preferences of the model so this
is uh more humanizing it than
probably is warranted there but uh
internal weights
it
had to create in order to create a model
for predicting the next token so let's
say for me to tell you what the next
token is you have to go to college for
four years and do well and graduate and
then I tell you the next token some of
those tokens are like that you have to
solve real world problems it's not just
every time I say letter Q letter U
follows you have to create those models
as a side effect and I think in the
process of accurately creating those
models and accurately creating models of
users to make them happy that you are
correctly predicting what they want you
create those internal states which may
be believes in those crazy things that
thing is there you just said there is
super interesting because uh so so next
token prediction is not a simple task
you're saying that to accurately predict
a token you have to develop perhaps a
world model at least for some tasks uh
right and as they get more complex some
people are worried about they'll have to
create perfectly accurate models of
humans which may also have Consciousness
and suffer and great whole simulated
universes within them but this is
probably a few levels above gpt4 but
still that's exactly the concerns you
might have you might be a suffering
human and AI is considering and just
trying to Outer complete somebody's text
prep is give me an example there what is
what is some next token predictions task
where you would have to develop a world
model well uh some playing chess or
something like that would require you to
have some notion of chessboard and
positioning relative to some array
within your memory but again we don't
fully understand it may not have a 2G
board at all it may have some sort of
just string of letters similar to DNA
and you know that after those strings
the following token follows and you have
no idea where chess is it makes just as
much sense the outcome can be mapped and
our model which is a 2d chessboard so
one one thing I discussed with the
mechanistic interpretability researcher
Neil Nanda is this question of how do
concepts arise in language models do
they even share our human Concepts or do
they perhaps develop some entirely alien
Concepts
I I'm imagining giving them math
problems giving large language models
math problems and them developing some
conceptual scheme that doesn't even make
sense to us they may have equivalent
Concepts which are not the same so with
humans when we say this is right
somebody could be colorblind and to them
it's a completely different concept but
we both point at the same fruit so it
works but you never know what the actual
internal experience is like for those
models and it could be just that in five
cases we talked about so far it mapped
perfectly but it goes out of
distribution in case six and it's a
completely different concept it's like
oh wow okay yeah for people listening to
this interested in trying to contribute
to the AI safety fields are there
perhaps some common pitfalls that you've
experienced with with perhaps some of
your students or people approaching AI
safety for the first time if if they are
technically inclined are there areas
they should avoid or how should they
approach the problem in in the most
fruitful way so probably the most common
thing is to try things without reading
previous literature there is
surprisingly a lot of literature on what
has been tried what has been suggested
and good survey papers as well so most
like directly your first intuitive idea
has been pride and dismissed or with
limited results deployed but it helps to
catch up with the field it's harder as I
said because there is not an archive of
formal papers in nature all about AI
safety and you can just read through the
last five years of latest and greatest
so you have to be good about finding
just the right papers and then narrow it
down but progress is so fast that when I
started I could read every paper in my
field then it was all the good papers
then it was well titles of all the
greatest papers and now I have no idea
what's going on we've been talking for
almost two hours there is probably a new
model out I don't know what the state of
the art is I don't know what the
solutions are so you need to be super
narrow and that makes it harder to solve
the big picture problem so that's
another reason I kind of suspect we will
not have complete expandability of this
whole large language model because it's
kind of encompassing all the text over
Publishers and the internet it'd be
weird if we can just comprehend that
completely what are the implications of
this field moving extremely fast does it
mean that that specialization doesn't
make sense or what what does it mean for
how people approaching this problem
should should focus on so that means
that we can analyze how bad the
situation is let's say it takes five
months to train the model but you know
from your experience in testing software
debugging understanding neural network
it will take 10 times as much time to
understand what's going on that means
you're getting worse off with every
release every model you understand less
you're gonna rush to judgment you're
gonna have incorrect conclusions there
is no time to verify your conclusions
verify your experiments so this is the
concern you need to if you go the
regulation route to say okay if you
deployed this model it took you x amount
of time to develop it we need 10x 100x
thousand X to do some due diligence and
your outputs even if you cannot prove to
us that it's safe you have to give
access to experts to poke around at it
and that amount of time cannot be less
than a training time of a model it just
doesn't make sense in terms of
reliability of your discoveries all
right Roman thank you for coming on the
podcast it's been very helpful to me
thank you so much for inviting me